MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everybody,
and everybody local and on
live stream.
I want to welcome Kara
Richardson Whitely here.
Her work as a plus
size adventurer
has been featured
in "New York Times,"
"Self," "Backpacker,"
"Weight Watchers," "Redbook,"
and also on Oprah's "Life Class"
and "Good Morning America."
We are very happy that she
was able to take time out
of her schedule to
come visit us at Google
and share her story with us.
Thank you.
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: Great.
Thanks.
So, hi, everybody.
I just want to get the
lay of the land here.
How many of you have
climbed Kilimanjaro?
Anybody?
OK, so nobody in the room.
Does anybody here want
to climb Kilimanjaro?
OK, one, two, three,
four, five, six.
Does anybody want
to be convinced
not to climb Kilimanjaro?
OK.
Three or four.
OK, got it.
So I'll talk to you a
little bit about my story.
I speak all over the country
about my journey up mountains
and sometimes up the scale, too.
So I'll share a
little bit of both.
And since there are
people in the room who
have the interest of
climbing Kilimanjaro,
if you-- still at the end
of the presentation-- still
have that interest,
I'll go over some tips.
And you can also contact
me afterwards also
if you have any
follow up questions.
So my journey up
Kilimanjaro began when
I was more than 360 pounds.
And at that time, I could
barely hike a staircase.
I couldn't even walk
around the block
without being completely out
of breath, totally uninterested
in continuing.
And I started to
think to myself--
because I was about to
turn 30 years old-- that I
wasn't living life anymore.
And you might think to
yourself, maybe you'll
meet somebody who's
really heavy or somebody
who struggles with weight,
and you just don't get it.
Like, why did they
get so big so fast,
or why can they
never get it right?
It's just food, right?
It's not heroin or
it's not alcohol.
But for me my
struggle with weight
started when I was nine years
old and my parents divorced.
And my father pretty
much up and left my life.
And then when I was 12,
I was sexually assaulted.
So it started with these
really big, traumatic things.
That's when I started
to use food for comfort.
And it started with
these huge things.
But then little by little,
I used food for everything.
And I really, truly
sugarcoated my life
where I wasn't feeling happy.
I wasn't feeling sad.
I was just feeling
pretty comfortably numb.
Because even when,
you know, my parents
were on the brink of
divorce, I literally
would hide in the pantry to
just drown out their screamings
by chewing food.
And when I was in the midst
of being sexually assaulted,
the only thing I could
think of to make it stop
and to get out of
the situation was
to get up and go to the
kitchen and offer the guy
something to eat.
And it threw him for such a
loop that it kind of ended
right there at that moment.
So in many ways food saved me.
But as I was approaching my 30th
birthday-- because at the time
I thought that was getting
pretty old-- I'm now 40.
I started to think, well
I'm not getting any younger,
and I have so many things that
I want to do with my life.
And I knew that I really
wanted to be a hiker
girl, because even though
I wasn't active at all
and I wasn't exercising
and I wasn't really
a member of a gym or
anything like that,
my life would light up.
My mind would just come
into that dream phase
any time I would get one of
those adventure travel catalogs
in the mail.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
Those glossy pictures of
the Alps and Machu Picchu
and Kilimanjaro.
But at that time,
I used to do what
a lot of people who struggle
with their weight do.
I'd say to myself,
well I'm going
to do that when I lose weight.
And I would say to myself,
I'll go to the doctors
when I lose weight.
I'll buy that dress or
I'll buy something fancy
to wear when I lose weight.
So as I approached
this birthday,
I realized that it was time to
just get moving no matter what.
And I decided that I
would just start to hike.
I would start to
just be a hiker girl.
And even though I'm not a
Patagonia model, of course,
I could start with things
like a water bottle.
I could carry a water bottle.
I could take flat hikes,
because I live in New Jersey
and there's lots of those.
And the more I hiked
the more I enjoyed it.
My husband-- he's
actually a marathoner.
He's done seven so far.
So he would hike with me.
And he would just
go up on the trail
and he would be far,
far ahead of me.
And then he'd tap his leg
like he was calling a dog.
Instead of yelling at him,
I would muster my energy
to go faster and hike harder.
And suddenly I was the one who
was picking the harder trails.
I was the one who was picking
more strenuous things to do.
And so as I got moving
with this journey,
I started to think
I need a goal.
Right?
And so I picked this
particular mountain as a goal.
Does anybody happen
to know where it is?
No?
It's called Camel's Hump, and
it's Vermont second highest
peak, because it looks
like the back of a camel.
And so anyway I chose this
mountain in particular
because when I was in college
at the University of Vermont,
that's when my weight went
over the 300-pound mark.
And obviously I wasn't doing
any hiking at the time.
The only walking that
I did was to the bars,
because they had
$0.25 draft night,
and that seemed to make
a lot of financial sense
to me, and to class.
And so even though
I grew up in Vermont
and I did hike Camel's Hump
during a 4th grade field trip,
because that's what they do
on field trips in Vermont--
they hike mountains.
When I was in college,
my friend said, hey,
it's a beautiful day--
a lot like it is today--
great sunshine.
It's June.
Let's go hike Camel's Hump
So I thought, hey, OK, sure.
I'll go along with you.
And 20 minutes into
this five-hour hike,
I was just completely
sucking wind.
I mean, absolutely out of
shape, unable to continue.
I had that feeling that many
marathoners do at mile 20
where you have lead leg, and
you can't move another inch.
And so I told them
everything, like oh, I
haven't been feeling well.
And I think my stomach hurts.
I must have eaten
something funny.
But the truth of the matter is
that I wasn't moving at all.
Instead of having it been one
of those Oprah aha moments--
that moment where
everything changes-- I
went to the bottom of
the mountain that day.
And I ate the two things
that were in my backpack--
a half pound bag of M&Ms and a
half liter bottle of Diet Coke,
because-- I mentioned
I'm not so good at math--
so I thought they
equaled each other out.
But for years and
years I lived that way,
and I decided that if
I was going to hike
and I was going
to be a hiker girl
and I was going to move more, I
needed to conquer Camel's Hump.
And so I hiked and I hiked.
And on the eve of
my 31st birthday,
I conquered Camel's Hump.
And the funny
story about that is
that I trained and I trained.
I trained on one of
those moving staircases--
the staircase that never ends.
You have one of
those at your gym.
That was like my best friend
while training for this.
And I thought about
it every day--
how I'm going to go to
the top of Camel's Hump.
And I decided I was going
to do a sunrise hike,
because I thought that sounded
glorious and amazing and like
one of those once-in-a-lifetime
kind of hikes.
So I get up to the
top of the mountain.
I'm hiking by myself.
And I'm, like, geez I don't
have anybody to take my picture.
And so suddenly this
woman and her daughter
start walking up with a dog.
I'm, like, oh, this is
such an incredible hike.
How long have you been
training for this?
They're, like, we do
this every morning
from the base of the mountain.
So I was joining a
different kind of lifestyle.
Even though it was
exciting and new for me,
this is something that
other people did every day.
And so I was really kind
of joining the club when
it came to hiking.
Once I conquered Camel's
Hump, well then the sky's
the limit, right?
Then I went down to the
bottom of the Grand Canyon
and thankfully back up again.
Because that is 10
miles of brutal--
has anybody done the
Grand Canyon here?
Yeah.
It's rough.
I mean, you really
have to time your rest,
how much food you're eating,
how much water you can bring.
It's a real endurance test.
And then we took on Vermont's
highest peak, which is Mt.
Mansfield, which to this
day is the hardest mountain
that I ever hiked,
because well, the truth
is that we ended up hiking down
the wrong side of the mountain.
So thank goodness the Vermont
Brewers Fest was the same day.
So as I was doing
all this hiking--
all this amazing hiking--
taking care of my body,
this great thing happened.
I started to lose a lot
of weight, so much weight
that I had lost
almost 100 pounds.
And this very strange thing
started happening to me.
Whenever I'd go-- especially
to the bathroom at work-- women
would follow me in there and
say, so what are you doing?
Why are you losing
all this weight?
Did you get the surgery?
Are you on Weight Watchers?
Are you doing South
Beach-- because that
was really hot at the time.
They'd be really interested.
And how long did it take you?
And what did you eat?
And what are you
eating for breakfast?
Tomorrow?
And what are you going
to have for dinner?
And can I join you for lunch?
And people would turn
and look every time
I got something to eat.
And that's all they cared about.
And these people who never once
gave an inkling about anything
in my life wanted
to know everything
that was going in my mouth.
And for someone
who had used food
for so long to kind of
cover emotions and kind
of cover myself, it was
incredibly intimidating.
So I decided that I wanted
to have another big goal.
But I also wanted to deflect
this attention I was getting.
So I started to set my
sights on Kilimanjaro.
Kilimanjaro is the
highest mountain
that you can hike to the
top of-- in other words,
no ice axes, no ropes,
no supplemental oxygen.
Have you seen "Into Thin Air?"
Right?
It's not that.
It's a long drudgery
kind of journey
where you're 5 and 1/2
days up the mountain,
1 and 1/2 days down.
But you can do it
on your own two feet
if you train really well.
So I figured that's going
to be the huge goal that I'm
going to focus on.
And because it's such an
iconic mountain-- I mean, even
in this room, there's five
people who really actually
do want to do this.
You can really do it to raise
money for almost any charity.
And so I thought since
I'm going to be doing it
in Africa that I
would do something
that would give back to Africa.
And so I did a
little Google search,
and I looked up
Kilimanjaro climbs,
AIDS orphans-- because
that's what I really
wanted to raise money for.
And lo and behold, I
found Global Alliance
for Africa, which is a
Chicago-based charity.
And the thing that
they do to raise money
for their organization
is Kilimanjaro hikes.
And so I signed up right away.
And then any time
that those women
who asked me about my weight
asked me what I was doing,
I'm, like, well I'm
training for Kilimanjaro.
And here is how you can
donate to AIDS orphans.
And I raised $12,000, so talk
about deflecting attention
there.
So to train for
Kilimanjaro, there's
a couple things you should know.
One is that it is 19,343 feet.
That's really high.
It's in Tanzania, Africa.
The keys to success are
to go [SPEAKING SWAHILI].
Does anybody know
Swahili in the room?
AUDIENCE: Slowly, slowly?
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: Yes.
Slowly, slowly.
That's right.
That's the key to success.
And so if I was going to
sign up for a mountain,
and they said, go as slow as
you possibly can, I'm, like,
yes this is my kind of mountain.
The other keys are drink a lot
of water-- up to five liters
a day.
That's a lot.
And the other thing is
have a positive attitude.
In fact, the only way that you
can tell if somebody is not
going to make it to the
top-- for those of you
who actually do want to hike
the mountain-- if you're
in your pre-climb
briefing, and somebody
is complaining about
how they hate camping
and they hate the
outdoors, they're
pretty much the goner by
day two-- just so you know.
But otherwise you don't
know who's going to make it
and who's not.
Martha Stewart
made it to the top.
Ann Curry, the newscaster
for NBC, didn't.
Martina Navratilova didn't.
So you just don't know
by looking at someone
whether or not they're
going to be able to do it.
So I like those odds.
To train I focused
on three things--
strength, stamina, and spirit.
Strength is pretty obvious.
You're doing a lot
of hiking, but you
want to also strengthen
your quads and your back,
because you're holding
a backpack for so long.
You want to strengthen the
muscles around your knees
so they support your body
and all the joints that
need to get you there.
Stamina.
Look, I live in New Jersey.
There were some
mountains I actually
had to hike twice to get
up to the level of being
able to climb Kilimanjaro.
But spirit I think was one
of the most important things
where I took yoga classes.
One-- because they do
a lot of breath work.
And I thought it was going
to be really important for me
to feel like I was in
control of my breath.
My breath wasn't going
to be in control of me.
And so even though there were
breath exercises that I did,
it started to really
kind of get me
in the rhythm of really
being conscious of air in,
air out, and conserving
air where I could.
But what I really
loved about yoga
as part of the training--
yes flexibility, strength,
all that stuff is great.
But every time I went down
into savasana-- you know,
the part where it looks
like everybody is sleeping
and they did nothing for
like a 45-minute class-- that
was when I started
to imagine myself
at the top of the mountain
before I got there.
Because I had to believe that
I could do this goal before I
did it.
So you can do a lot of
routes up Kilimanjaro.
I in my three climbs have
climbed the Rongai route
each time.
It's the route on the
Kenya side of the mountain.
It's a little more remote.
Maybe when we camped we saw
two or three other groups,
and that's it.
On the way down the mountain,
we went the Coca Cola route,
which is much more--
there's much more traffic.
And so you really did
see a lot more people.
A lot of people look
at this middle photo
and they say, oh, how wonderful.
They are just starting
their-- it's OK.
A lot of people
look at this photo
and they say, oh, how cute.
They're just starting their
journey up Kilimanjaro.
And I have to explain
to them, no, no, no.
That's four days in.
And you still have to
do-- summit night is
from here up to the top
and then halfway down
the mountain in one day.
It's 15 hours of hiking.
And things like altitude--
headaches are a real concern.
This is Lisa, who actually
did make it to the top,
but it was 50-50 whether
or not she was actually
going to continue or
not at that point.
So hiking Kilimanjaro
is an amazing thing.
You dream about it for months.
You prepare.
You visit REI more times
than you probably have
in your entire life, right?
You spend more money on
gear-- probably as much
as you paid for
your plane tickets.
But then comes summit night.
And when you're
at summit night--
and I mentioned that
you're camping kind of high
up on that slope
that I just pointed
to-- when you start
your summit attempt,
it is 15 hours of hiking.
So why not start at midnight?
Right?
Get it started and
get it over with.
When you open your
tent door, you
are so high up that there
are stars above you.
There are stars beside you.
There are stars below you.
When you are so
proud of yourself
that you've put on every
possible layer of gear--
everything.
You look like that kid
in "A Christmas Story."
I can't put my arms down.
And you've managed to
tie your shoe laces
at about 15,000 or
16,000 feet-- that
alone is, like, you're
so proud of yourself
that you can't even imagine.
So then you walk out your tent
door, and you join your group.
You try to stomach a
little bit of breakfast.
And then you start walking in
this formation with your guide.
And they're singing you Swahili
love songs and lullabies
as you're walking in
this beautiful formation.
Lockstep-- everybody's
in this together.
And that's really wonderful--
for the first hour,
maybe the second.
But by the third
hour, you're thinking,
I think this guide is lost.
Because unlike in
states where there's
these big trailblazes where
you know exactly where you're
going, there's I'm going
to follow the red dot
trail all the way
up the mountain.
There isn't that on Kilimanjaro.
There's just these gravelly
trails of scree near the top
where you take one step up,
and you slide halfway back.
And you take another step up,
And it is so
incredibly frustrating.
So then you're really
irritated at this point.
And by hour four, you've
pretty much got your I
quit speech down.
Like, listen.
I really want a fresh
shower and a cold beer
or a cold water that
comes from a bottle
not from whatever water source
you got this stuff from.
You guys are like sisters
or brothers to me.
You've lent me toilet paper.
I feel like we're family,
but I'm going to leave now.
I'm going down the
mountain the way I came.
So right when you feel like you
just cannot take this journey
anymore, that's when
the sun comes up.
So on Kilimanjaro--
especially on summit night--
it is truly darkest before dawn.
That's when you really have to
dig in and just keep pushing
forward when you feel like you
just can't-- unless, of course,
you're suffering from
something really, like,
altitude sickness.
But usually your mind gives
out before your body does.
And if you're
climbing Kilimanjaro,
usually you stop at Gilman's
Point where you can have tea.
A lot of times the porters and
guides have tea for you there.
And you're so high at
this point that you
watch the sunrise over Africa,
and the horizon is curved.
And when I first noticed
this, I thought maybe
I was tripping because
of the lack of oxygen.
But a lot of other people
confirm that the horizon does
look completely
curved, because you
are so high up in the world.
But maybe they had
lack of oxygen, too.
So from there you can go
on to Uhuru peak, which is
the true summit of Kilimanjaro.
And the first time I did
it, I hiked with my husband.
And for the record, he's only
done one of my three climbs.
So with all my training, I
kept thinking about the way
up, the way up, the way up.
But what goes up must come down.
Right?
And so it can be kind of fun.
I mean, you're doing
this scree running.
So now that scree that
was so devastating to you
on summit night-- so difficult
to manage-- is kind of fun,
because now you're doing this
almost like a vertical run
down a beach.
Does that make sense?
So you're trying
to have fun with it
where you're just kind
of running and running
and running.
And it really
actually helps rinse
out the lactic acid that's
kind of built out in your body.
But you just try to
enjoy the journey
down even though your legs
kind of feel like jello for all
that you've put it through.
So as we're doing this,
as we're making our way
down the mountain that first
time, all we could think about
was getting to a
hotel-- shelter,
anything over our
heads, a warm meal
at a table on a
plate-- something
that we could really enjoy.
And, of course, a shower.
Our leader at the time,
she said to us, hey, guys.
Don't forget to look up
every once in a while.
And so on this
particular trip where
we were at that moment
on the mountain,
I looked up in
the horizon, and I
saw a mountain that looked
a lot like Camel's Hump.
And I thought to myself,
gosh, if I had never
done Camel's Hump-- if I had
never made that my giant goal--
I could never be here.
And so it really does make a
difference, those small steps,
those interim goals.
So even if it's like a
five K for you-- something
you've never done before-- you
never know where that may lead.
And it might just
lead to the five K,
and that alone is a
huge accomplishment.
And Camel's Hump at the time
was a huge accomplishment,
but that interim goal led
me to the roof of Africa.
So in the end, I
did lose 120 pounds.
And the women were very excited
about that who would follow me
to the bathroom.
And after I came back from
Kilimanjaro, the next thing
they wanted to know, so
what's your next adventure?
What are you doing?
Are you going to do Everest?
Are you going to
do Machu Picchu?
Are you going to do-- if
"Wild" were out at the time,
they would have been,
like, oh my god.
You totally got to do the
Pacific Coast Trail, right?
But I had a whole other
adventure in mind.
It required another language
and a lot of new gear
and that was to have a baby.
So like a lot of women who
struggle with their weight,
I put on a ton of it back
on when I was pregnant.
In fact, I put on 70 pounds
during my nine months
of pregnancy.
And I went from someone that
had been to the roof of Africa
to someone who could barely
hike across my living
room, because I had
sciatica so bad, which
is like this lightning
bolt down your leg.
And it was embarrassing.
It was embarrassing
that I had done so much.
In one year I lost
all this weight,
and then in months I put
half of it back on again.
And so now those women wouldn't
even look me in the eye
anymore.
They wouldn't hold the
door for me anymore.
Nobody really wanted to talk
about weight anymore with me.
And so I was really
feeling stuck and isolated,
and I started to do those things
that I did when I struggled
with my weight before.
I'd bow out of events, because
I felt like, oh, I'm too fat.
I don't want to go
to that reunion.
I don't want to go that party.
I haven't seen this
person in a long time.
I wouldn't be in family photos.
In fact, there's almost
no pictures of me
when I was pregnant.
And I think it's
because I didn't
want people to take my picture.
I was embarrassed of
how I felt about myself.
And I was really stuck.
And I started to think
about what was it
about that first
Kilimanjaro climb?
How come I was able to really
rise above and just go do it?
And I thought to
myself, well, it
was because I was
working for a cause that
was bigger than myself.
Whenever I didn't
want to work out,
I thought about I'm climbing
this mountain for AIDS orphans
in Africa.
I'm raising the money for them.
Who am I to not eat well?
Who am I to not train today?
They're depending on me.
And even though if I didn't
make the top of the mountain,
I still would have--
the donations still
would have gone to the charity.
But I felt like I had a
responsibility to do my best.
And so in my
post-pregnancy mind,
I thought, well I've
got a great plan.
I'm going to do
something called the Save
the World workout,
where I'm going
to do a different
event for charity
every month of the year.
And that way I would force
myself to get out and be
a part of an event where they
are raising money for charity,
where I have to sign
up for it, show up.
And it really did
a great job of just
at least getting
me moving again,
because that's something
I wasn't doing at all.
So even though
some of the events
burned more calories than
others-- like the flying pig
marathon-- I actually walked
the whole marathon course.
But the penguin
plunge in Vermont--
which is jumping in Lake
Champlain in Burlington,
Vermont in February,
where they actually
have to cut out a minivan
sized chunk of ice,
and you jump in the water--
that was more about me
kind of getting out of
my shell again than it
was about burning calories.
And I'm a little embarrassed
about the profanity
I used in front of the
former mayor of Vermont,
not Bernie Sanders,
but Peter Clavelle.
But I think he might have
matched it a little bit,
but I'm not saying he did.
So anyway it was this
great year of just kind
of getting out, raising
money, doing fun things
that I enjoyed again.
And I thought, OK, the
best thing that I can do
is to end the year with
a Kilimanjaro climb.
And that will
finally get me back
in that space, that
same place where
I was successful with weight.
I mean, because you know, you
see all the advertisements
for weight loss products, weight
loss surgery, weight loss this,
weight loss pills, weight
loss-- all these programs
that you can do.
People really want to
be in that place again.
And I desperately wanted
to hang on to something.
And I thought Kilimanjaro is
going to be the key to that.
And so I thought if I just
ended with a Kilimanjaro hike,
I was going to be
able to do that.
So I did all the
events, but the problem
was I convinced
myself that I was just
really good in altitude.
And it's just a slow
hike to the top.
It's all you have to do to get
to the top of this mountain.
Unfortunately, it isn't.
If you're planning on
climbing Kilimanjaro,
you want to give yourself
four months of training
in that direction,
and that's it.
You want to make sure you
have time to prepare your body
and your mind for this.
But the most important
thing that I did not conquer
was my challenge with food.
Because I didn't put 70
pounds back on because
I was just eating
extra ice cream.
I was doing the same
things that got me
into trouble the first time.
I was binging, and my
real red flag with food
is when I can't
admit what I ate.
In fact, my real
trouble point with food
is when I'm hiding
what I've done.
So for those of you who
don't struggle with food,
I'll just lay it out for you.
This is what it looks like.
I'm the mom in our family,
so I do the grocery shopping.
Right?
I come home with some ice cream
for my kids-- for my daughter
at the time and my husband.
And we have dessert.
We have a nice healthy portion
of ice cream, and that's that.
Everybody's happy.
We go to bed.
The next day while
I'm working from home,
I think after lunch I
could use some ice cream
or sometimes after breakfast.
I could use some ice cream.
I have a little bit.
I want to be done with it.
Then I return to the
fridge or the freezer
a few minutes later,
maybe an hour later.
I want a little bit more
and then a little bit more.
And suddenly I'm eating
the entire container
with a spoon with the
freezer still open.
And suddenly I'm,
like, oh my gosh.
This thing is almost gone.
Now how am I, a professional
mom, a professional writer,
a good mom, successful
in lots of other things?
I mean, I've raised money.
I'm a good person.
How is it that I can be
conquered by a cupcake?
And so then I do what I think
is the most logical thing.
I go back and I have to buy
another thing of ice cream
to hide the fact that
I didn't eat the ice
cream in the first place.
And this is when I'm really
in trouble with food.
And this is where I was on the
eve of this second Kilimanjaro
climb.
I hadn't dealt with how
I was feeling with food.
In fact the hardest thing that
I had to write about in "Gorge"
was the scene right
before the second climb.
Because I had purchased
some candy in the Amsterdam
airport for my daughter
and my niece and nephew who
were coming to
visit for Christmas,
and I ate it all--
every single bit of it
on the eve of a
Kilimanjaro climb.
So spoiler alert.
I didn't make it up
the mountain that time.
In fact, it was a
pretty devastating fail.
And after that point, if I
was in the red flag territory
before, I was seriously,
seriously in trouble with food.
I did that kind of
thing with ice cream
like almost every single day.
So I didn't want to hike again.
I didn't want to hear
about Kilimanjaro again.
I didn't want anything
to do with mountains
until a friend of mine
said, hey, remember
that trip up Kilimanjaro?
Ever since you talked
about it with me,
I've always wanted to go.
And I'd like to do it to
train for an Iron Man,
so my friend would also
like to come with me.
And together we will raise
$1 per foot of the mountain
for the charity that you love.
So $19,343 was on the
line for Kilimanjaro
if you come with us.
And then I had my
husband's cousin, who
is on the cover of "Gorge"
with me, say to me, you know,
I'm in a rut.
I really need to get out of it.
Her mom died of cancer,
and then her father
was murdered on the
roadside in Moab, Utah--
all within a couple
years of each other.
And she was eating and she
was shopping to kind of get
through those feelings.
And so she was putting
on a ton of weight.
She's, like, I just need
something to keep me going.
So I'll climb
Kilimanjaro, and I'll
raise $5000 for Global Alliance
for Africa if you come with me.
Talk about backwards
peer pressure, right?
So now I knew if
I climbed that I
could raise an additional $5,000
for Global Alliance for Africa.
So now we're talking about
$30,000 for this organization
that I really loved.
I mean, that's more
than enough money
to actually build a library
in one of the slums in Kenya
or anything like that.
I mean, there's
so much that could
be done with that amount
of money for the programs
that they use.
So I thought, OK, I'll do it.
However if I do it-- and this
is the story that's in "Gorge"--
that I would need
to do the work.
I would have to do
the training again--
that kind of four to six months
of really, really training.
However, the most important
thing that I needed to do
was to love myself where
I was and go from there.
Because initially I started
to do that thinking, like, OK.
I'm going to lose 20 pounds this
month and 10 pounds every month
until the hike.
And that'll be perfect.
I thought, no.
If I set myself
up like that, it's
going to be a complete failure.
What I needed to do was to find
a trainer who would train me
as I was that I could be
able to climb the mountain
at the weight I was at.
I did things like I signed up
for a half marathon in Vermont
called the Mad
marathon, which is
the most mountainous
marathon-- half
marathon-- I've ever walked.
It's incredible.
And my husband did that
with me to help me train.
But more importantly,
I needed to understand
what is it about food
that has so captured me?
How come I eat?
How come I have this
pattern of existing
that is so dangerous to myself?
So if I was going to
climb the mountain, not
only was I going to do
it upon my own strength
and my own body,
I was also going
to do the work to understand
the journey that I had been on.
And this, of course,
was no walk in the park.
I climbed the mountain
as if I was carrying
another person on my back.
I did the hiking as
if I was doing that.
So I did things like I trained
in Telluride with my husband's
cousin, Stacy.
And you know, PSA-- it's a lot
easier to ski down a mountain
trail than to hike up it.
Because that was some serious
hiking up some serious trails.
But it was so gorgeous
when I got to the top,
and I was doing actually
altitude training because those
are like 12,000 feet--
14,000 feet-- peaks
that we were hiking.
So when I got to
the mountain, when
I got to there the third
time, I was feeling
pretty great about myself.
I was feeling like I was ready.
In fact, so much so that by
the second day, two of the four
people who were with us--
four including myself--
were feeling sick,
feeling tired, feeling
like they had made a mistake,
like they didn't really
want to come up Kilimanjaro.
And how could I have said
yes to this crazy idea?
Anyway, I started to feel
like, yeah, I feel good.
Even after that second
day on the Rongai route,
which is 10 hours of hiking--
10 hours of just drudgery.
It's not a huge incline,
but it is a long slog.
The porters and
guides actually asked
me, hey, do you need me to
carry your backpack two or three
times, because they
were already carrying
backpacks of my fellow hikers.
I'm like, no, no.
I feel good.
And so that night when I went
to sleep, I was thinking, OK,
it's so cold.
It was actually
so cold that night
that our water bottles
froze in our tents.
So if you go camping a lot,
you know that kind of night.
All you want to do is put your
sleeping cap on, put yourself
in your sleeping bag, go
to sleep so you can wake up
for when the sun rises,
and it could possibly
be a few degrees warmer
when you wake up.
So as I was going
to sleep, I started
to hear rumblings in Swahili
in the tent next to me.
That's where the porters
and guides were hanging out.
And I don't know
a lot of Swahili,
but I do know a couple things.
The most important
thing that I know
is what they call me in Swahili.
My nickname on the mountain
for all three climbs
was Mama [SWAHILI].
Which means big woman--
which didn't bother me.
That's the way they
differentiate me
from the other people.
They know who they're
talking about.
But then I started
to hear laughter.
And it wasn't like
Mama [SWAHILI]
had told this really
funny joke, and I'm
going to tell you what it is.
I knew at that moment that
they were making fun of me.
And so these are the
people that we were paying
to help us up the mountain.
And I started to feel
for the first time
like I'm not going
to do this anymore.
I've done this.
This is my third
time up the mountain.
I know my way back.
I'll just get a ride to
the hotel, and I'm out.
Because I started
to think to myself,
I'm not going to do this.
If the people that we're paying
to support us up the mountain
don't think I'm
going to make it,
how could I possibly make it?
So I finally lulled
myself to sleep.
I remembered things like when
I was doing spinning classes,
and they did these
mantras, and I totally
tried to get myself into the
mode where I was, like, OK
I believe in me.
I'm going to ignore
what they said.
But here's the thing
about Kilimanjaro.
You can't push off things.
If it's raining, you
put on a rain jacket
or you will get soaked.
If you're hungry, you
need to eat something
or you're going to be-- you're
not going to have enough energy
to do what you need to do.
If you're thirsty,
well then you're
far beyond being dehydrated, and
you need to be drinking, right?
The same thing
goes with emotions.
It's a really great
mountain to kind
of toil through
something that you
need to figure out, because all
you have time to do is think.
But you have to do
something with that emotion.
And for me, as someone
who's been struggling
with their weight since
she was nine years old,
I know when people
are making fun of me.
And I couldn't just
put it off anymore.
And I'll just do a
quick reading about what
happened after that point.
So the next morning
I was still feeling
upset about how they felt--
what they said about me.
However far I walked,
however much I
tried to think of other things,
the humiliation of last night
was there, and it was raw.
I was overcompensating by
being perky-- a cheerleader--
even if I would have
never made it on a team,
let alone be on
top of a pyramid.
But being perky and positive
was how I usually dealt
with everything in public.
I needed to confront
Kennedy but in such a way
that he would continue guiding
me up the mountain safely.
So when it came time for
a water and pee break
amid an outcropping of
rocks, I approached our guide
with what I always do when
I am upset or nervous.
I smiled.
I didn't want him to know
that his mocking words made
me want to turn
back, so there I was
swallowing my true
feelings, trying to be nice.
After all his job
was not an easy one.
He was already carrying
Tracy's backpack to help her,
but my cheeks burned.
I always live with the feeling
that I couldn't or shouldn't
speak up in the face of bullies
or my abuser or even my father.
I was used to swallowing my
words like 22 rifle shells.
So when it came time
to say my words,
I nearly choked on
the first syllable.
I want to talk to
you about something,
I said, interrupting a Swahili
conversation he was having
with our assistant guide.
Last night I heard you.
You were talking about me.
What were you saying?
Sorry, Kennedy said.
I was pretty sure he
was pretending he didn't
know what I was talking about.
I heard you last night.
I heard you making the
trails I do when I'm
going up and down the trail.
I heard you making fun of me.
I was talking with some
porters who wanted to know,
are you sure she's
going to make it?
I was answering them.
They don't believe you're
going to make it to the top,
Kennedy said.
He looked
embarrassed-- maybe not
because of what he said
but for getting caught.
From his tone the
night before, I
couldn't help but think that he
was one of the people betting
against my success.
I knew his laughter, and I
believed he was laughing at me.
They don't believe it, I asked.
Yeah, Kennedy
answered, looking away.
Did you make any
money bets, I asked.
You should, I said.
Bet on me.
So that's the only
time in my life
probably that I've
been able to come back
with something to
say to somebody
who's making fun of me.
In middle school it was
just an embarrassment.
I would just hear
people making fun of me,
and I would just run away.
And then I'd think
about it two days later.
And the only thing
that I can think of,
of why I was able to say
something with such power
and conviction and strength
was because Kilimanjaro allowed
me to feel strong,
and so I can ask
for what I need for in life.
I can do things
that I want to do,
because I was finally
standing up for myself.
So my wish for you is
that whatever it is you
want to accomplish--
if after this talk
you want nothing to do with
Kilimanjaro-- whatever it is,
whatever goal you have
is that you continue
to bet on yourself.
Because it will always pay
off for you in the end.
So thanks, and I'll take
any questions that you have.
AUDIENCE: I'm planning a
Kilimanjaro hike in June.
So first one.
I normally hike around the
Bay Area, so what do you think
will be most surprising
or shocking to me?
Or what should I do
extra to prepare?
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: OK.
So the most
surprising or shocking
is when you're shopping
for hand wipes,
multiply the amount
that you think
you need by about four or five.
The training that you
do is pretty obvious.
You want to hike up mountains.
You want to build strength.
You want to build endurance.
But the hardest part
is the mental part--
going past what you think you
could possibly do on your own.
That's hard.
But then also
enduring that when you
feel kind of yucky
about yourself
because you haven't showered.
I mean, they give you--
at least the tour group
that I went with-- gave you
water to wash up and stuff.
But you just feel so
grimy by the end of it.
And that can be kind of tough
to endure-- the physical.
You know, usually if
you hike around home,
you do a great day hike.
Then you go home or you go
to a hotel and you shower.
Backpacking is not like
that where you actually
have to be where you
are and continue being
in that mode for several days.
So really prepare not only the
physicality of the mountain
but the emotional part, too.
AUDIENCE: I want to
know what inspired
you to write about this book.
Is it the first
book that you write?
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY:
I did write a book
that I self-published called
"Fat Woman on the Mountain,"
and that was about
my first climb.
And I self-published
that because I
was 90% done on my computer.
And I thought, well, I
might as well just share it
with the world.
But this is my first
book with a publisher.
And I've been lucky
enough to work
with Seal Press, which
is actually based nearby
in Berkeley.
They're a publisher
for women by women.
But as I was working
to get the proposal
ready-- because a nonfiction
book you write a proposal.
You don't have to write
the whole thing at first.
But you have to
write a good portion
and know where
the book is going.
My agent, Kim Perrell,
had mentioned that she
was looking at the proposal.
And I was really focusing
on the mountain climb.
I'm a fat person, and I'm
climbing this mountain.
Isn't that great?
It was an adventure story.
And she and I had what was a
very difficult call for her
to make and say that
this is a great story.
Of course it's important
for you to tell the story.
But I need you to be more open
with your struggles with food,
because that is
equally as important
as this physical struggle
to hike a mountain.
And she assured me-- then
writers like Cheryl Strayed,
who's my teacher--
she wrote "Wild"--
that it didn't matter what I
put on the table about my issues
with food.
Because 2/3 of the United
States struggles with weight
in some way, shape, or form.
And so it didn't matter
how open or embarrassing
I thought a story would
be-- that there would
be a lot of people
nodding their head
or understanding someone
else's behavior because of it.
And so that's what
I decided to do.
And with that advice, I
actually changed the title.
I had originally called
it "Big, Fat Mountain,"
which I still think was
kind of a good title.
But as I was writing the last
scene, which is in a gorge,
I thought, oh my gosh.
It has to be "Gorge."
Because it means so
many things-- to eat
too much in the low point
between mountains and also
slang for gorgeous.
But that's a third meaning.
It was mostly those two
meanings, of course.
So anyway the paradigm
of sometimes you
get some feedback, and even
though it's difficult to take,
it really was important
for me to hear that
and really write to that point.
And once she did that, I felt
like the floodgates opened.
I could share anything.
In "Fat Woman on
the Mountain," I
shared about being
sexually assaulted
and my father not being a
real big part of my life.
But in "Gorge," I really
kind of let it all out,
which was really
important for me to do.
AUDIENCE: Are you planning to
climb again, by any chance?
KARA RICHARDSON
WHITELY: Well, I think
it's safe to say it's time to
move on to other mountains.
You know, Kilimanjaro
three times-- I mean,
maybe Oprah could ask me to
climb it, but that's about it.
But I would love to
hike Machu Picchu.
I mentioned I studied
with Cheryl Strayed.
I did that in the French
Alps, so I do a lot of hiking
when I was there.
But the most important thing
for me at this point in my life
is that hiking comes
naturally to me.
So it's not something that
I put a barrier up because
of my size.
Or have I lost 10 pounds?
Have I gained 10 pounds?
You know, wherever I'm at
the scale that I love it,
in fact, so much so that I'm
an American Hiking Society
ambassador to share that the
outdoors are for everybody.
But you know, my victories
today aren't huge mountains.
They are things like before
I left on these two talks--
I did a talk at
Purdue-- I made sure
that I had my seeds ordered
for my community garden plot.
So I had healthy things
for my family to eat.
There are things like
going to family swim,
because putting a bathing
suit on for me can
be as intimidating as Everest.
OK?
Let's just be honest here.
You know, so that I actually
am leading an active life,
no matter where I am on the
scale, for myself, for my kids,
for my future.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
wipes and I saw the poles
and I've read the blogs.
Is there any kind of
equipment that you needed
that you didn't think
you would have needed
or that you didn't read about?
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: Well,
if you go with a reputable tour
company, they will
give you a supply list.
So you can feel pretty
comfortable about that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY:
The people at REI
won't steer you wrong usually.
I would say that the most
important thing for you
to put money into is into
your socks and boots.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: I am
not a fancy bag kind of person,
even though there's a
Bloomingdale's in the next town
over, I never go there.
But if I go to REI, I drop
$300 on a pair of boots,
but it's so worth it.
I bought a pair of
Asolos that actually I
took up Kilimanjaro three
times and all the training
in between.
And the only reason I
gave them away at the end
was because our guide
was wearing Skechers.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KARA RICHARDSON
WHITELY: You know?
And so you want to make
sure-- as a side note--
if you do decide to
climb the mountain,
you want to make sure that
your guide company really takes
care of their porters, because
it's considered a good job.
However, you want to
make sure that they
have good footwear, that they
have enough to stay warm.
Because you'll see how much
you pack, and it'll depend--
there's guidelines about
how many pounds it can be.
But then you see these porters
are carrying up all your stuff.
And then theirs is a
tiny little backpack.
So think about that,
for sure, when you go.
But hiking poles-- it's good
to start training with them,
even though you don't
think you need them.
Because it does take a
lot out of your shoulders
to kind of move with them.
So you don't want to be
feeling like that is something
new for you on the mountain.
You really don't want anything
to feel really totally
new for you-- any of your
gear-- except for maybe
gaiters, because those go on
the outside of your pants.
AUDIENCE: One last follow up.
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I read somewhere
that you wanted your shoes
to have a little bit of
space, so when you come down,
your toe doesn't seem crammed.
But that seems kind of odd
in the sense that going up,
you don't really want
loose boots, either.
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: Huh.
AUDIENCE: Was that an
issue when you came down?
Did you feel like your
toes were getting smashed?
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY:
Well, yes and no.
I mean, it's an
interesting question.
You want to feel that with
your outfitter, whoever's
selling you your boots, and
look more online about that.
I mean, because I've
had-- my third climb--
by the time I got
down the mountain,
I had this horrible blister,
which I won't describe.
Because it's probably
like adult content.
You don't want to
hear about that.
On my toe.
But I think it's because my
laces weren't tight enough.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
KARA RICHARDSON
WHITELY: I was probably
too tired to just go down
and tie them tightly.
You want to make sure all
those things are taken care of.
Another thing is you want to
make sure your toes are really
well clipped and your toenails.
Because if you have too long
toe nails, that will also--
you'll lose a lot of
toenails because of that.
So lots of tips.
Lots of footwear.
Ask lots of questions.
I mean, the people who
work at outdoor stores
often do it because they love
gear, and they love hiking.
And so if they don't
know, then someone else--
I'm sure someone on their
staff has done a similar hike.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you.
KARA RICHARDSON WHITELY:
Thank you so much.